[Music]  I understand exactly what you're going  through  Nick Carter tears up after watching a  heartfelt performance on boyband that  hit close to home  [Music]  that's 16 year old contestant Jayden  gray earlier in the show he got candid  about his tumultuous relationship with  his father I have to start with you  Jayden when it comes to having a hard  upbringing in a family and you know no  matter what happens or what they say or  do you still love them if it was  beautiful there was everything that this  world needs it's been a difficult week  for the Backstreet Boys singer after his  younger brother Aaron's DUI arrest on  July 15th Nick tweeted his support  Nathan made no efforts to call me how  about all the other options that he had  how about calling me in jail why don't  you want Nick's help  I don't need Nick so I don't need that I  don't need help what I need is people to  [Music]  understand that I'm human